[Music]
so at the moment if we want to measure
what the brain is doing if we want to
measure brain function there are a few
ways of doing it but one way is Magneto
and so photography or meg
the idea of Meg is that we measure
magnetic fields that exist outside the
head that are generated by current flow
in the brain and in that way we can work
out what the brain was doing at any one
time the problem with current M eg
scanners is that they're very large
they're very bulky and they're
one-size-fits-all the gap in the market
if that's the right expression is for a
scanner which you can wear on your head
so you put it on like a helmet you can
wear it on your head whilst we're
acquiring brain imaging data
so to build a wearable imaging system
you really need two things you need very
very sensitive magnetic field sensors
that a small lightweight and that can go
on the head and that's what we had with
the quantum sensors and then you need a
way to house them on the head and so to
do that we built a 3d printed head cast
and that would house the quantum sensors
close to the scalp and that was designed
based on a single subjects head shape I
volunteered to be the subject and yeah
that's so this helmet accommodates 13
sensors which are over the motor region
the right motor region of my brain I'm
putting it all together you just fit
yeah so it fits perfectly in my head
the quantum sensors give us the magnetic
fields that are produced by our brain at
any one time and by knowing also the
location of these sensors with respect
to the brain we can localize which area
of the brain was responsible for the
movement and also when that part of the
brain was engaged and that in the
certain task
ideally we would be looking at something
more generic like something like a bike
helmet which could be adaptable to any
anyone's head size and could just hold
the sensors without having to build
something specifically perfect for just
one person there are a number of
challenges but probably the biggest one
we had was reducing the Earth's magnetic
field so if you want somebody to be able
to move with a scanner on their head and
that scanners measuring magnetic field
you need to somehow remove the Earth's
magnetic field
so when they told me on day one that my
job was going to be to remove the
Earth's magnetic field that sounded more
like a joke they tell two new starters
than anything else the way we went about
this was to build these new
electromagnetic coils that produce
fields that are equal and opposite to
the Earth's magnetic field so the
mathematics required to design these
coils to reduce the magnetic field is
actually quite quite complex it's quite
a large challenge but then once you've
got past all of that the actual making
of the coils is bits of wood bits of
masking tape bits of gloom bits of wire
so it's a massive contrast really him
what you know what you doing there um
housed on two planes either side of the
subject so you got then going down here
one going down here and that keeps the
scanner quite open you can walk in and
out of it
crucially it meant that the sensors
wouldn't fail if the subject moved even
by a tiny amount and that meant that any
information we were getting from the
sensors we knew was coming from the
brain and then we would be able to do
these cool experiments with this new
technology
scanning babies two-year-olds
two-year-old four-year-olds and is going
to become possible so that brings into
play a number of different disorders
like epilepsy but also things like
autism I think we will certainly be able
to to really start seeing the neural
substrates that underlie these these
disorders in children
[Music]
so I get this rid of this
[Music]